for all the answers we got at the end of
endgame there are still a few nagging
questions that weren't entirely summed
up by the time those credits rolled some
of these questions go back multiple
films in the franchise while others were
introduced in endgame and then seemingly
abandoned what are we talking about snap
on your spoiler gloves because we're
digging deep to find all the unanswered
questions from Avengers endgame once
again to be clear spoilers ahead there
was a lot of mantle passing in the
closing moments of endgame much of it in
a heartwarming fashion old man cat
passing his shield on to Falcon it
doesn't get much better than that we've
got a more grown-up Cassie Lang in the
picture and Clint hit a bull's-eye with
his daughter but what about iron man
who's set to replace him the obvious
choice is of course little Morgan Stark
her father even died in a battle with an
intergalactic wacko stuff that in a box
and label it origin story but if that's
the timeline the MCU is taking it raises
the question when is the next time we'll
see a version of Iron Man on the big
screen Morgan's what four years old less
than five for sure because of the snap
innings by the time she's old enough to
strap on some nanites the rest of the
Avengers will be hanging up their own
suits months before end games release a
theory was making the rounds that Tony
Stark would make his own Infinity
Gauntlet and reverse Thanos a snap
it didn't happen quite like that but the
theory was pretty dang close and it
brought up some really interesting
points that we were all hoping would get
answered an end game 1 is the idea that
Tony has been feeling echoes across time
from using the stones across several
movies Tony Stark has been having
problems with his arm if he had such
immense power at his fingertips some of
that power might ripple backwards
through time and give him arm problems
as far back as Captain America's Civil
War but infinity war brought that ripple
even closer to home
remember how Tony Stark had a dream that
pepper had a baby girl and they named
her Morgan a dream like that could have
been another echo from the future since
future Tony knew that he had a daughter
when he used the Infinity stones and its
placement in the film just before
endgame has to be more than a
coincidence suit roses and that
just in case there's months from the
closet he said you know insurance
unfortunately it's all still just
speculation since NJ never really
addressed that in any way infinity Wars
big thing was unquestionably as a snap
Thanos foreshadowed it then the final
battle came and he upheld his promise
turning half the universe into dust with
a snap of his fingers cinematically it's
great
it's won instantly identifiable gesture
of annihilation that also says look how
easy it is to clean up the universe from
a comics perspective it holds up well
since that's what Thanos did in Infinity
Gauntlet
so then endgame comes along and the only
way to make the stones work is now
snapping is that in the Infinity manual
when Professor Hulk put on the glove the
first time he was clearly picturing what
he wanted to happen since he says he
also tried to bring back Natasha and in
the final battle both Tony and Thanos
try snapping the movie never answers the
question of whether there are other ways
to use all the stones after all if
they're powerful enough to bring back
trillions of life forms with all their
memories and costumes intact wouldn't
just wishing be enough without the snap
let's face it
any movie dealing with time-travel is
going to run into problems for its part
though endgame did wrap up a lot of
loose timelines explain most of what
needed explaining and keep the plot
moving out of all the time-travel
shenanigans one question that was almost
definitely intentionally left unanswered
was the 2012 Loki's whereabouts if you
remember while in the past after the
Battle of New York stark fumbled the
tesseract and Loki snagged it while no
one was looking and slipped away into a
portal by doing so he presumably created
a different timeline that didn't end up
with that version of himself being
choked by Thanos so now there's a rogue
Loki roaming around another timeline but
the movie leaves that guy's fate
completely unmentioned what kind of
mischief is he getting up to with the
ability to travel anywhere in the
universe sorry about this thing with the
tesseract I just couldn't help myself
there's a huge disconnect between the
way the Infinity stones are built up in
the previous movies and the way they're
handled in
and game literally handled in guardians
of the galaxy the collector gave a whole
PowerPoint presentation that explained
how only a being of extraordinary
strength can wield an infinity stone a
few seconds later his lady servant
grabbed the power stone and exploded to
prove to audiences that he wasn't lying
so sure using the stones is devastating
but it's pretty clear what these stones
can do to you just by touching them
fast-forward to the end game though and
people are tossing around the stones
like hot potatoes for starters Hulk and
Hawkeye both held a stone in their bare
hands
granted those are plausible at least the
Hulk is if nothing else a being of
immense power and just like fan oohs
Clint Barton was given the soul stone in
exchange for his sacrifice so maybe he
was allowed to hold it even so it's not
like the stones in the gauntlet are
shielded by anything and yet half the
Avengers got in on that game of
keep-away with the glove none of those
mortals even brushed a finger across an
infinity stone
none of them caught it wrong or slapped
a palm over a reality stone or two when
Peter Parker comes back during that epic
final battle
he tells Tony that he must have passed
out because when he woke up back on
Titan stark was gone the implication
there is that time didn't pass for the
people who were dusted five years went
by in the real world but all the dust
bunnies came back just thinking they'd
taken a quick nap it goes by pretty
smoothly mainly because there's so much
other stuff happening then but during
the wrap-up scenes when we see Peter
back in school reuniting with Ned you
start to wonder how is society going to
reconcile what happened it's convenient
that all of Peters friends were
apparently also dusted so now they get
to finish going through high school
together but what about the rest of the
world most of these people essentially
blanked and city filled suddenly looks
like the apocalypse little Susie's in
college Grandpa Joe's kidneys failed
he's dead
picture that but multiplied by billions
the world is going to have a whole heck
of a lot of work to do fixing things up
and endgame didn't touch on that
question at all finally the most
important question of all is who does
put mayo on a hot dog
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
Avengers endgame are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]